is it your 10th anniversary coming up
it'll be 10
in april yeah wow coming from a
broken home and and my parents divorced
when i was 14 it's like sometimes you
never really
for me at least i mean really honest
like i never you never know what's gonna
happen i don't know if i ever thought
that i'd make it ten years with anyone
and so honestly and so like to be with
him and to know that our relationship is
so strong and
knowing that it's even stronger being in
covet and
being able to to remain like super you
know super connected and
we've been doing a lot together and i'm
very proud of us and he's such a good
dude
like he's he's got a heart of gold he's
such a great dad and
you know it's a it's wonderful being his
wife it's a good thing
do you have any big plans no i mean does
anybody have any plans right now i mean
honestly right yeah right i mean this
year we looked at each other and we're
like
well it'll be fun 10 next year we're
gonna do it up and then now we're like
well maybe 11 because who knows
we might just still be sitting in our
sweats on the couch which is totally
fine with me
well for now the grammy winner is
focusing on her other big milestone
the 20th anniversary of coyote ugly
of course leanne sung several of the
songs in the cult classic
and to celebrate she just released a
special mega mix
[Music]
how would you describe the leanne rhymes
of
20 years ago oh my gosh i was such a
little kid i was 17.
i was kept to this like really innocent
little girl you know from the time i
started out so that movie
and that movie was kind of like my
innocence gone like
here's leanne dancing in a barn some
sexy clothes i was really kind of
emulating everything that was going on
um everything that was around me because
i was still coming into my own as a
woman i was so awkward still
like trying to figure myself out and
then i watch it now and i'm like man
that hair flick was good i had some
moves down like i was faking that really
well
are your boys aware of the legacy of
this movie like have they seen
mom as a 17 year old up on the bar
dancing and singing
i don't know if they have that's a good
question i'm sure they've seen a clip of
it here
or there um yeah but we never really
talk about it too much
you know we're just like i'm just a step
mom and every once in a while
the youngest like he's 13 and he'll come
out and watch
you know some of the shows and he's like
kind of amazed at
how i do the thing that i do in front of
so many people
um it's cute to see them kind of take it
in every once in a while but yeah other
than that i'm just that annoying stepmom
who
wakes them up you know early and too
early in the morning for
to go to school so like wait 10 more
minutes